[Musique]
Emilie Nicolas Christian Dufour
Madeleine blémorin bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir c'est incontournable il faut
reparler encore de ce rapport Johnston
pas d'enquête sur l'ingérence chinoise
a-t-il recommandé parce que trop
d'éléments secrets je vous fais entendre
des petits extrêmes sur poilievre vous
allez voir Monsieur Blanchet et Monsieur
Trudeau parvient tout de suite
Jack meeting fasse son travail
en forçant son partenaire de coalition à
tenir une vraie enquête publique pour
que les Canadiens puissent savoir la
vérité c'est le rebondance
le mandat de Monsieur Johnson était de
protéger Justin Trudeau de protéger le
Parti libéral du Canada de protéger le
secret en général et ce faisant il aura
servi à protéger les abus de la Chine
sur le territoire canadien
quand on entend les attaques des chefs
d'opposition on voit que c'est des
attaques personnelles contre Monsieur
Johnston c'est pas un désaccord avec ses
conclusions un questionnement de son
travail surtout que on a affaire à tous
les chefs de l'opposition
d'avoir d'accéder à la cote de sécurité
nécessaire pour pouvoir regarder
l'intelligence sur lequel ces conditions
ces conclusions ont été fondées
alors Monsieur Trudeau qui pose une
question que je vous pose d'une certaine
façon est-ce que l'opposition ne
pourrait pas une journée ou deux
expliquer pourquoi ça prend absolument
une enquête publique et non pas
constamment revenu sur le fait que
Johnston Madeleine n'est pas crédible à
leurs yeux parce que il y a eu une
proximité avec la famille Trudeau
c'est certain que ça fait une grosse
différence Patrice si à leurs yeux
monsieur Johnston n'est pas crédible
parce que à peu près tout le monde
s'entend pour dire que peu importe la
forme d'une enquête que ce soit celle de
Monsieur Johnston que ce soit une
enquête publique tout ne pourrait pas
être rendu public il y a personne qui
prétend ça on parle de renseignements de
sécurité nationale donc ça devient
crucial que la personne à la tête de
l'enquête soit crédible mais aux yeux de
l'opposition ils prétendent qu'elle ne
l'est pas crédible cette personne-là
David Johnston en raison de ses liens
avec la famille Trudeau en raison avec
la Fondation Trudeau donc selon les
parties d'opposition monsieur Johnston
mais on parle du Bloc québécois et du
Parti conservateur n'aurait pas dû être
nommé à la tête de cet exercice là
n'aurait pas dû être rapporteur spécial
parce que là on arrive avec un rapport
qui n'est pas complet il y a une annexe
qui est caviardée une annexe
confidentielle oui les parties
d'opposition de vie avoir accès mais les
parties d'opposition disent en fait le
Bloc québécois le Parti conservateur
c'est un piège parce que si on a accès à
cette information là après ça on peut
plus en parler publiquement de toute
façon donc voyez-vous non ils peuvent
dire j'ai lu les éléments confidentiels
je vous passe la parole Christian et je
ne suis pas d'accord avec la conclusion
avec laquelle interview monsieur Johnson
au moins ils auraient les faits je
comprends que c'est un paratonnerre
gentil je comprends le l'euro de
l'opposition aussi mais je comprends
moins qu'on débatte pas au Canada la
question qu'on est posée au monsieur
est-ce que on doit enquête publique ou
pas il dit il faut pas on peut être en
désaccord mais parlons de ça mais
peut-être je suis dans le champ
Christian
la réaction des parcs d'opposition est
un peu compréhensible mais moi je trouve
que vraiment réussi à l'exploit parce
que moi j'ai jamais vu un rapport être
aussi mal accueilli ce matin en fait
j'ai écouté un taux de commentaires j'ai
eu un tas de texte tout le monde était
négatif je sais pas lu un commentaire
positif au sujet de ce rapport-là quelle
exploit il faut dire que la plupart des
gens s'attarder à ce qu'il recommande la
tenue dans le cadre public là évidemment
on attire l'attention sur le fait que au
départ c'est vrai que c'est un mauvaise
nomination parce que pas de crédibilité
au départ mais je pense aussi qu'un
autre problème c'est que sur moi nous
avait suggéré une voie de sortie crédit
pour sortir de cette espèce de on est
enlisé là-dedans donc mais il y a
uneanimité c'est fascinant en fait à
quel point tout le monde est négatif à
l'égard de ce rapport-là peut-être que
je dites-moi le je suis quelqu'un qui a
trouvé ça positif mais moi j'ai rien lu
j'ai rien entendu positif je te rappelle
Émilie
la première c'est que ce qui est
absolument pas nécessaire d'avoir des
vies Johnson Johnston pour avoir une
enquête publique le gouvernement aurait
pu avoir une enquête publique
directement je pense que le débat sur la
nécessité ou non d'une enquête publique
c'est fait
c'est fait en mars en fait avant même la
domination de David Johnson c'est plus
le courant on discutait du sport et du
compte puis c'est là où il y a eu les
arguments notamment du gouvernement qui
disait justement une enquête publique ça
se peut que on puisse pas parler de
certaines choses de leur public parce
que les renseignements confidentiels ont
lieu à cette époque-là puis ils ont
utilisé David Johnson pour
essentiellement gagner du temps en
disant mais on va avoir un rapporteur
spécial qui va vous redire espérons-le
ce que nous ce que nous on vous disait
déjà c'est à dire que c'est pas une
bonne idée d'avoir une enquête publique
ceci dit ça ça règle rien et
effectivement ça aurait été bien d'avoir
dans ce rapport-là au moins une voie de
sortie ou une alternative si c'est
effectivement pas une bonne idée d'avoir
une enquête publique parce qu'on
pourrait pas aller plus loin je pense
qu'il y avait pas trop à moi c'est
sincèrement un problème donc si je
comprends bien tous les chroniqueurs au
pays achètent Madeleine et Christian et
Émilie cette idée qu'il est la
marionnette de la famille Trudeau puis
qui le rend un petit service en fin de
carrière
je dirais pas jusque-là Patrice
premièrement c'est pas uneanimité dans
les dans les chroniqueurs et c'est pas
tout le monde qui dit que c'est une
marionnette mais le fait que il n'avait
pas la crédibilité aux yeux de
l'opposition le disqualifie d'une
certaine façon c'est pas que il a
volontairement voulu jouer le jeu du
Parti libéral c'est qu'il n'a pas la
crédibilité nécessaire pour remettre un
rapport qui n'est pas entièrement public
est-ce qu'il y a du bon dans ce rapport
là il y a des choses qui sont
intéressantes dans ce rapport-là par
exemple on lit qu'il y a des problèmes
de communication majeure entre
l'information qui vient des agences de
sécurité et le gouvernement par exemple
on se fait on donne les agences de
sécurité donnent des renseignements au
gouvernement sans domine de noms à qui
s’est adressée donc on dit tel document
est destiné au ministère X Y ministère
de la Sécurité pour donner un exemple et
il y a personne qui est nécessairement
responsable de le lire et les agences de
sécurité par la suite font pas de suivi
est-ce que ce rapport-là a été élu quand
des responsables du gouvernement se
rendent parfois dans des pièces
sécurisées pour lire des rapports ce
sont des volumineux rapports il y a
personne qui va dire bon faites
attention la page 5
dans la structure il dit un manque de
communication entre les agences et le
gouvernement entre autres c'est pas
mineur c'est pas mineur parce que
l'information qui est colligée de façon
responsable ne fait pas nécessairement
son chemin jusqu'au gouvernement qui lui
doit prendre des décisions par la suite
comme des pressions sur Michael il écrit
dans son rapport ça serait dû être le
gouvernement réduite au courant il ne
l'a pas été dépression qui n'ont pas qui
n'avaient pas toujours été exercée
dit-il sans donner des détails mais les
Chinois est en train de réfléchir à la
patente oui Christian
le sûrement des bonnes choses dans ce
rapport-là le problème c'est qu'on est
rendu ailleurs c'est que l'opinion
publique est rendue ailleurs et depuis
au public c'est un petit moment qu'il
fallait avoir une enquête publique qui
ont rappelons-le le choix le choix de
Monsieur Johnson était vraiment
erreur donc à ce moment-là on peut on
peut ergoter sur ce que dans le rapport
ou pas c'est pas le manger
on peut en parler mais honnêtement il me
semble que les Canadiens sont fermés à
ce rapport-là et puis on est rendu
ailleurs il faut savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire pour sortir en fait de cette
enlisement c'est c'est ça que je
reproche personnellement il y a au moins
du suggéré quelque chose pour aussi
faire des grosses erreurs et attaquer
les médias quasiment dit que c'est de la
faute en fait des médias je suis avec un
peu mais ça c'est plus
que les médias mais indiquent les
lanceurs d'Aleg n'auraient pas dû parler
aux médias mais
dit que les maisons
j'en ai vu d'autres
ce qui me frappe dans cette histoire-là
Émilie Christian et Madeleine c'est à
quel point
pour reprendre le mot à la mode que je
déteste mais qui explique bien le
narratif de l'opposition a été acheté et
a coulé par ce que bien sûr il y a des
médias qui ont beaucoup d'influence qui
c'est comme si on ne voulait pas se
poser la question est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée ou c'est pas une bonne idée
d'enquête publique c'est comme si tu es
devenu le nouveau et je veux des débats
je dis pas que je suis pour ou contre
j'ai pas d'opinion moi mais j'aurais
aimé qu'on débatte de l'enquête publique
et non pas du monsieur c'est ça que
j'essaie de dire maladroitement Émilie
en fait je pense que c'est important
justement pour répondre à ces questions
là de comprendre effectivement un peu
comme l'éducation la question des médias
là-dedans parce que quand même quand on
voit ce qui est écrit dans le rapport il
dit que le en fait le globet de merde et
global ont mal évaluer la disons le
niveau de crédibilité des renseignements
qui sont publiés c'est quand même gros
et c'est là dessus que toute la saga des
mois c'est basé c'est sur le travail du
globalement et global et ce qu'il dit
aussi c'est que Handon qui est un député
libéral qui avait été accusé donc de
passer d'informations consulat à Toronto
il dit que en voyant en ayant eu les
informations confidentielles qu'il a
cette information-là qui a été publiée
par le globe
que pour lui c'était pas c'était pas
crédible et là ce qui se passe c'est que
oui le globamel et le globe continue à
faire le travail de
bien pouvoir à couvrir cette histoire là
mais on s'entend c'est que il y a aussi
une question de protection de de sa
réputation journalistique qui est
là-dedans donc les médias deviennent à
la fois
exactement
cette histoire-là c'est sûr que ça
influence la manière dont cette
histoire-là est reçue et l'opinion
publique dont on parlait Christian ne se
constitue pas de nulle part c'est sûr
que lorsque les grands médias canadiens
ont pu on pousse dans un sens et que la
Rigou est sur la table ça aide à
construire l'opinion publique aussi dans
un sens
très bien mais discussions enquêtes
publiques ou pas qui va se poursuivre
parce que les parties on verra comment
va se positionner le NPD parce que c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui ce poids lièvre
dit à Monsieur signe levez-vous et dites
Christian que vous allez pas protéger
votre ami Monsieur Trudeau là-dessus
une opportunité puis le NPD parce qu'on
est c'est fascinant parce que c'est
comme un coalition quelque part en fait
qui gère le Canada de depuis quelques
temps la question est de savoir jusqu'où
va aller le NPD avaler des couleurs
certains points parce que là on en
demande beaucoup donc très peu le jeu
admire Patrice votre professionnalisme
quand vous dites vous aurez voulu avoir
un vrai débat sur le fond je fais un
devis
parce que j'ai tout lu ce matin là je
lis tous les matins tous les chroniques
et
c'est comme un arbre qui cache la forêt
et j'aurais aimé qu'on discute plus du
rapport
c'est pas le dernier venu non plus puis
à moins que des faits
voilà il y a son avocat mais je
m'emballe je m'emballe parce que je
voulais éviter Véronique à se joindre à
nous
parce que je veux quand même qu'on parle
de quelqu'un qui parle de chez vous
Madeleine et qui sera à Québec monsieur
sait bien chez hydro ça fait beaucoup
réagir trop de tables là-dessus est-ce
que c'est un choix qui vous étonne non
Madeleine très rapidement puis je vous
dis au revoir après est-ce que c'est un
choix qui est étonnant la part du Québec
d'après vous mais en tout cas je l'avais
pas vu venir à Ottawa pour être
complètement en France j'avais
l'impression que c'était vraiment
l'Allier de taille de Christophe Willem
elle reposait entre autres sur lui
Christian Freeland a pas nécessaire on
fait sa marque encore comme ministre des
Finances parfois on se demande même si
c'est ça qui l'intéresse vraiment ou
davantage les affaires étrangères donc
elle comptait sur Michael c'est bien ou
du moins c'est l'impression que ça
donnait donc c'est un choix qui est
surprenant en tout cas pour moi vu
d'Ottawa très bien Véronique aujourd'hui
l'opposition c'est amusant il n'est pas
encore nommé officiellement et
l'opposition seulement oui mais quel
expertise a-t-il dans le monde de
l'énergie
c'est sûr qu'on s'attendait à ce que ce
soit un candidat qui est spécialisé en
matière d'énergie mais d'un autre côté
moi c'est une nomination là éventuelle à
être entraînée par le Conseil des
ministres ne m'étonne pas du tout parce
que dans ce même panel je vous avais
déjà dit que le critère principal il ne
l'avait pas dit au micro mais le critère
principal selon mes sources pour le
candidat c'était de trouver quelqu'un
qui allait faire plus plus vite et
Michael sedia va faire plus plus vite
parce qu'en réalité mes sources me
disent Hydro-Québec la croisée des
chemins et là il y a des défis énormes
qui l'attendent en matière de production
d'électricité puis c'est défi là au
niveau de la transition énergétique
c'est pas Hydro-Québec qui voit les
relever ça va être le gouvernement ça va
être la responsabilité du ministère de
l'Environnement puis gros Québec ça va
être un outil Hydro-Québec dans tout ça
devrait être plus performant puis
Michael c'est bien c'est un gestionnaire
de grandes organisations c'est ça qu'il
fallait oui ça va bousculer la machine
il y a des gens là-dedans qui sont là
depuis 10-15 ans qui sont habitués mais
ils sont habitués de manière de
fonctionner puis on se dit oui ça va
peut-être les bousculer mais ça prend de
la performance ça prend du développement
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement le
goût considère que c'est ça nomination
la plus importante de ce mandat
Christian
c'est bien vous inspire
c'est bien c'est vraiment un poids lourd
c'est quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
respecté puis au Québec c'est pas
n'importe quoi au Québec bon quand on
dit évidemment il est pas c'est
priorités c'est pour les changements
climatiques ou même l'énergie faut pas
oublier que le gouvernement logo au
départ c'était pas sa tasse de thé les
changements climatiques puis je pense
que le fond reste là on s'adapte au
contexte on veut être moderne puis on
verrait tant d'autres préoccupations des
gens qui qui trouvent que c'est dans
dangereux mais en homme quelqu'un qui je
pense au diapason de Monsieur legroste
que l'on demande il y a vraiment un
choix politique là-dedans on est plus
dans le développement ça veut pas dire
qu'il s'occupera pas d'environnement
puis des changements climatiques mais ça
veut dire que ça sera pas sa priorité
numéro 1
qu'il y avait le problème avec Madame
Brochu un élément qui était intéressant
c'est que Monsieur c'est bien ce sera
pas une marionnette le monsieur fait du
Gabin qu'on aurait pu craindre c'est
quelqu'un qui se tient debout donc je
trouve une nomination qui se défendent
du fait qu'on a un gouvernement de la
CAF ils n'ont pas de Québec solidaire si
vous voulez Émilie
vraiment je trouvais ça vraiment
intéressant aujourd'hui de voir la
différence entre les réactions du milieu
des affaires et ceux du milieu d'énergie
ou des experts en environnement puis
essentiellement
si le milieu des affaires semble heureux
de ce que j'en comprends c'est que c'est
que les gens pensent qu'il va qui va
respecter la vision de développement de
François Lebois avec lesquels ils sont
d'accord et que si les gens du secteur
énergétique sont nerveux c'est parce
qu'ils souhaitait avoir un quelqu'un à
la tête d'Hydro-Québec allait pouvoir
expliquer les défis en énergie a fait du
Gabin et on se dit que finalement il va
pas nécessairement ma conseillé sera pas
nécessairement la personne pour faire ça
il va pas l'expertise pour le faire mais
il y a peut-être pas aussi la vision
disons politiques pour le faire aussi
donc les gens qui voulaient avoir
à la tête d'Hydro-Québec un espèce de
personnes pour essayer d'avoir de
tempérer peut-être
une certaine ou un contrepoids qui a une
expertise pour dire mais voici la
meilleure façon ça sera pas le cas ce
sera pas le cas et je pense que c'est
pour ça notamment que cette déception là
du côté du secteur énergétique merci
merci beaucoup à vous quatre désolé pour
mes emportements Christian mais on va on
va se reparler au contraire on aime ça
on va reparler de ça parce qu'on va en
parler jusqu'à la prochaine campagne de
cette enquête publique à Dieu au revoir
merci
[Applaudissements]